ce documentaire a été réalisé à l'aide
d'un site internet que j'ai créé
moi-même et qui a besoin de votre aide
wiki archive.space il regroupe tout
simplement la plus grande collection de
photos spatiales du web elles sont
accessibles gratuitement en
téléchargement et le site internet et
sans pub en revanche son coup de
fonctionnement est assez cher et c'est
pourquoi si le cœur vous en dit et si
vous en avez les moyens vous pouvez
soutenir le site web en faisant un don
sur la page pas très long de wiki
archives sur ce je vous souhaite un bon
visionnage
il y a près de 20 ans la première
navette spatiale américaine qui avait
ouvert la voie d'un programme aussi
important qu'ambitieux se désintégrer
au-dessus du Texas après une mission
scientifique de 16 jours et causant la
mort de cet astronaute
aujourd'hui nous revenons en détail sur
la mission l'accident et les récits de
ce dont il a changé le destin à jamais
[Musique]
nous sommes le 1er février 2003 à
Houston au centre de contrôle de la NASA
les contrôleurs de vol surveillent la
rentrée atmosphérique de la navette
spatiale Columbia et c'est 7 membres
d'équipage qui reviennent d'une mission
purement scientifique de 16 jours en
orbite basse terrestre en direct sur CNN
les journalistes interrompent leur
programme pour couvrir l'événement
[Musique]
tout semble correct mais des alarmes
commencent à apparaître sur la
télémétrie les contrôleurs relèvent que
les censeurs de l'aile gauche affichent
des données hors limite au niveau de la
température
le contact est rompu comme prévu dans
cette phase et Houston attend patiemment
qu'il soit rétabli
au même moment au bord de la piste 33 du
Kennedy Space Center c'est le branle-bas
de combat les véhicules d'assistance
attendent la navette qui doit arriver à
9h16 précisément selon les calculs de
Houston un double banque supersonique
annoncera son arrivée en Floride comme à
chaque fois marquant les derniers
freinages de Columbia avant de se poser
les familles des astronautes sont toutes
présentes dont celles Dylan Ramon
première astronaute israélien et fils de
survivants de la Shoah renard Ramon sa
femme raconte
dans les haut-parleurs j'ai entendu une
mission contrôle dire quelque chose de
pas clair un frisson m'a saisi les cieux
se sont obscurcis et nous restions là à
sourire nous prenions des photos et nous
sourions nous étions sur les bords de la
piste et le compte à rebours s'égrainer
en face de nous comme lors du lancement
tout est silencieux autour de nous trop
silencieux les dix dernières secondes
s'affichent et nous les comptons à
revoir haute 10 9 8 7 mais rien ne se
passe la foule s'agite il y a un silence
de mort on nous demande de nous
rassembler les communications étaient
perdues et la raison n'est pas claire
des gens commencent à pleurer je regarde
le ciel et je prie le Seigneur qui le
ramène à moi
je ne demande encore ce qui se passe
mais on ne me répond pas
le monde entier savait mais nous étions
encore debout sur les gradins à prendre
des photos souriants et impatients le
monde entier savait mais pas nous
une pluie de débris s'abat sur tout le
Texas sur CNN après quelques minutes de
doute et d'incompréhension des images
arrivent du Texas la chaîne WFA a filmé
ce qui semble être une rentrée
atmosphérique anormale on annonce alors
au directeur de vol Lee rockane ce qui
est en train de se passer dans le ciel
au-dessus de
il ordonne de fermer les portes ce qui
signifie que les données de tous les
postes de contrôleur doivent être
sauvegardés et ne doivent pas être
touchés pour l'enquête ce qui est la
procédure en cas d'événements potentiels
[Musique]
au même moment des habitants de la
région de Palestine appelle CNN et donne
leur témoignages
[Musique]
comme le note le journaliste
norme astronaute ne peut que confirmer
les craintes
a Houston la responsable médicale Jackie
Reese prend les contrôleurs à part loin
de la salle de presse pendant plusieurs
minutes elle les prépare à surmonter
psychologiquement la tragédie la NASA
prépare une conférence de presse et
informe le président George W Bush
l'administrateur de la NASA de l'époque
Sean au kiffe raconte le jour de
l'accident ce jour si émouvant est
difficile c'est devenu clair pour moi
que l'agenda de la NASA ne serait plus
jamais le même tout l'éventail
d'objectifs de gestion et de grandeur
que l'on avait jusqu'à la veille était
désormais fini
le chapitre était clos car j'en ai
informé le président il a immédiatement
demandé et je ne l'oublierai jamais où
sont les familles c'était le premier
objectif s'assurer que les familles de
l'équipage étaient protégées de la
presse et des paparazzis il fallait que
ce soit notre priorité ce jour comme
ceux qui allaient suivre le second
objectif était de rassembler tout ce que
l'on savait de l'accident je ne suis pas
en regardant sur l'heure mais il faut
être honnête avec les Américains dira
tous ce que l'on sait et répondre
honnêtement si l'on ne sait pas disait
le président les équipes de recherche et
de sauvetage de force worth vers Dallas
sont activés les autorités locales
établissent des périmètres de sécurité
autour de chaque débris retrouvé la NASA
prévient les citoyens s'il trouve un
débris il ne doivent en aucun cas le
toucher pour des raisons de sécurité et
doivent contacter la police locale ou la
NASA directement chaque morceau de la
navette sera utile à l'enquête
en ce qui concerne le sauvetage des
astronautes il faut se rendre à
l'évidence à plus de 200 000 pieds
d'altitude et plus de Max 16 il n'y a
plus aucun espoir de survie de
l'équipage
16 jours plus tôt au Kennedy Space
Center Columbia s'apprête à décoller
pour la 28e fois de son histoire son
commandant Rick asband embarque pour son
second vol depuis sa tendre enfance il
est passionné par l'espace ayant assisté
au vol Mercury Gemini et Apollo voir les
atterrissages lunaires c'était si
inspirant excitant à mes yeux que je me
suis dit il y a aucun doute c'est ce que
je voudrais faire quand je suis élégant
dès qu'un avion passe dans le ciel le
petit Rick asband ne peut s'empêcher
d'arrêter de jouer et lever les yeux au
ciel il est plus que décidé à réaliser
son rêve et va suivre le cursus
classique et parfait pour y parvenir
diplômée d'ingénierie mécanique second
lieutenant dans l'US Air Force il cumule
3800 heures de vol sur plus de 40
modèles différents d'avions et devient
pilote d'essai et instructeur mais la
sélection à la NASA ne sera pas facile
après 4 candidatures et deux entretiens
il est finalement sélectionné en 1994
c'est à l'accomplissement d'un rêve
d'une vie c'est excitant d'enfin faire
le genre de choses que je voulais faire
depuis si longtemps
sa femme Evelyne raconte Rick était un
grand fan de John Young donc quand
celui-ci lui parlait RIC notait tout et
archivait le calpin car il disait que
c'était profond et intéressant une des
choses que John Young a confié Harry qui
était ne donne pas tout à la NASA il
prendront ton âme si tu les laisses
faire cela venait de quelqu'un qui avait
travaillé pour la NASA pendant des
décennies marcher sur la lune et vécu
une longue vie et c'était un très bon
conseil que Rick a pris à cœur et je
pense que ce conseil s'applique aussi
aux épouses d'astronautes son rêve se
concrétise le 27 mai 1999 sur la mission
STS 96 où il est le pilote de la navette
Discovery pendant 9 jours il goûte aux
joies du vol spatial et à l'honneur de
piloter la navette vers la toute
naissante Station Spatiale
Internationale pour la première mission
de ravitaillement de celle-ci
c'est aussi le premier amarrage officiel
d'une navette à la station
quelques jours après son retour sur
terre il apprend qu'il commandera STS
107 il m'a raconté à quel point son
équipage était génial il a énuméré
chacun d'entre eux et ma tout raconté à
propos d'eux et leur famille il m'a
aussi décrit qui ils étaient en tant que
personne quelques jours avant le
décollage recles band entre dans une
période de quarantaine très attaché à sa
famille ses enfants ont du mal à le
savoir loin d'eux pour rester
virtuellement auprès d'eux l'astronaute
enregistre une vidéo pour chaque jour
qu'il passera dans l'espace
chaque matin les enfants recevront une
cassette pré-enregistrée de leur père
leur disant qu'il est fier d'eux qu'il
lui manque et qu'il reviendra bientôt
faire vent chrétien croyant et très
pratiquant il n'a pour autant aucun
problème à fédérer un équipage au
croyances et origines différentes comme
celui de STS
117isme y compris avec des personnes de
foi et culture différente il était
capable d'en parler de façon intime sans
que quiconque ne se dise oh non il
essaye vraiment de me convaincre de
croire les mêmes choses que lui RIC
avait juste le don de partager sa foi
sans offenser celle des autres
à ses côtés dans le cockpit se trouve
William McCool au poste de pilote de
Columbia c'est son premier vol spatial
détenteur d'un diplôme en sciences
appliqué d'un Master en Sciences de
l'Informatique et d'un autre master en
ingénierie astronautique il s'engage
dans l'US Navy et devient pilote
embarqué sur les porte-avions
USS et USS Enterprise totalisant plus de
400 à pontages et 2800 heures de vol
particulièrement intéressé par l'aspect
scientifique de la mission il dira tout
ce qu'on fait là-haut c'est créer des
technologies pour le futur ce qui les
utiliseront et les feront évoluer sont
les enfants d'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de plus grande expérience en tout cas
dans ma carrière que de voir la joie et
le rêve dans les yeux des enfants quand
on leur parle de nos expériences
attaché à sa famille comme son
commandant il aime particulièrement les
randonnées avec sa femme et ses enfants
il a promis à Lagny son épouse
photographe qu'à son retour il
l'aiderait à terminer un livre de
photographie avec lui il emporte dans
l'espace leurs deux alliances et des
photos de leur mariage
tout comme Rick asband le spécialiste de
mission David Brown a toujours rêvé de
devenir astronaute et tout comme William
McCall ce sera son premier vol spatial
je suis né un peu tard pour Mercury mais
je me souviens de Jimini et Apollo suivi
de Skylab et des premiers vols de
navette mais j'arrivais pas à
m'identifier aux astronautes je les
voyais comme des stars de cinéma et
j'étais qu'un gamin comme les autres je
ne voyais pas comment un gamin normal
comme moi pouvait un jour être comme ces
gens forcément même si je pensais que
c'était le job le plus cool qui existe
ce n'était pas du tout quelque chose que
j'imaginais faire un jour il obtient un
diplôme en biologie un doctorat en
médecine et intègre l'US Navy en tant
que médecin de vol
il est le premier médecin de vol de la
Navy à devenir pilote embarqué en 1990
il totalisera 1700 heures de vol avant
d'être finalement sélectionné comme
astronaute de la NASA
[Musique]
la spécialiste de mission calpana chaola
et la première femme astronaute
d'origine indienne né à carnal en Inde
elle y fait ses études et obtient en
1982 son diplôme en ingénierie
aéronautique elle déménage ensuite aux
États-Unis pour intégrer l'université de
Texas Harlington elle y décroche un
master en ingénierie aérospatiale et est
engagé par la NASA au centre ayms après
une brillante mais courte carrière dans
le domaine de l'aérodynamique elle est
sélectionnée par la NASA comme
astronaute en 1994 elle réalise son
premier vol sur STS 87 en tant que
spécialiste de mission où elle a
l'occasion de manipuler le bras
robotique de la navette Columbia
il faisait nuit en Inde au moment du
lancement mais ils étaient tous levés
pour le regarder la ville avait décoré
ma maison natale avec des guirlandes ils
avaient organisé des retraites aux
flambeau c'était comme un jour de fête
nationale mon décollage était important
pour l'Inde moi j'étais impressionné
parce que je m'attendais pas à un tel
engouement passionné d'aviation depuis
l'enfance elle aime particulièrement en
est son mari en vol elle détient sa
licence d'instructrice de vol civils sur
avion et planeur mais également les
licences de pilote privé et commerciales
quand on lui demande avant STS 107
quelle figure l'ont motivé à suivre
cette carrière elle répondra dans mon
cas je pense que la motivation et
l'inspiration viennent tous les jours
des personnes que je croise c'est facile
pour moi d'être motivé et inspiré en
voyant quelqu'un qui donne tout pour
arriver à un résultat par exemple
certains professeurs dans les écoles
l'énorme est fort qui font pour
présenter un cours le temps
supplémentaire qu'ils allouent pour
faire des expériences avec nous les
compliments qui donnent à leurs élèves
pour avoir vous présenter de nouvelles
idées bref je me demande toujours où il
trouve la patience de faire tout ça
Michael Anderson spécialiste de mission
réalise son second vol avec sts17 fils
d'aviateur il baigne dans le milieu
depuis sa tendre enfance
diplômé en physique et astronomie il
s'engage ensuite dans l'Air Force où il
totalise 3000 heures de vol sur cassé
135 et t38 il est recruté comme
astronaute en 1994 est réalise son
premier vol sur STS 89 une mission à
destination de la station Mir je suis
sûrement différent des autres
astronautes car je n'aime pas du tout
les décollages je trouve que les
lancements sont horrible manière d'aller
dans l'espace mais actuellement c'est la
meilleure manière d'y aller en fait
c'est même la seule mais une fois qu'on
arrive en orbite et qu'on est dans
l'espace c'est là que je me mets au
travail et que je transforme cette fusée
en laboratoire orbitale
passionné d'automobiles il est perçu
comme assez introverti sauf quand on le
lance sur deux sujets sa famille et sa
Porsche sa vie privée est très réservée
peu de personnes dans son entourage
savent qu'il est astronaute et c'est une
chose qui lui va bien pour le reste
c'est un accro du travail qui a du mal à
garder du temps pour sa femme et ses
deux enfants malgré l'amour qu'il leur
porte
[Musique]
Laurel Clark est spécialiste de mission
sur sts107 contrairement à ses
coéquipiers l'aviation et l'espace ne
faisait pas partie de ses rêves
d'enfants je me suis intéressée aux
missions lunaires comme tous les gens de
ma génération mais je n'ai jamais
vraiment voulu devenir astronaute ou
travailler dans l'espace je
m'intéressais plutôt à l'environnement
les écosystèmes et les animaux c'est
donc tout naturellement qu'elle suit un
cursus en zoologie et obtient un
doctorat de médecine tout comme David
Brown elle devient médecin dans l'US
Navy mais pas sur un porte-avion son
environnement sera sous l'eau auprès des
plongeurs et des équipages de
sous-marins
c'était pour moi une progression
naturelle quand j'ai appris ce que les
astronautes de la NASA faisait et le
genre de choses qu'il devait accomplir
j'ai pensé aux choses que j'avais faites
jusque là et cette suite de carrière
m'intéressait
elle est sélectionnée par la NASA en
1996 il faudra attendre 2003 pour son
premier vol STS 117 quelques mois plus
tôt l'oral Clark et sa famille ont été
victimes d'un accident d'avion à
l'atterrissage l'avion fut détruit mais
la famille entière s'en sont sortis
indemne yein le fils de John et Laurel
Clark encore sous le choc redoute qu'il
arrive quelque chose à sa mère lors de
son vol spatial il la supplie de ne pas
partir sur cette mission mais elle ne
renonce pas elle dira
un navire est en sécurité au port mais
ce n'est pas la raison d'être d'un
navire
Ilan Ramon est un ancien pilote de
chasse de l'armée israélienne à l'âge de
23 ans il avait écrit au professeur
yeshiaou lay-bovitz scientifique et
philosophe des questions sur le sens de
la vie il écrivait à quoi bon mourir
pour son pays est-ce que donner ma vie
pour un autre changera quoi que ce soit
dans le monde son expérience au combat
est la mise en danger de sa vie pour la
guerre ne lui plaisait plus il avait
envie de servir une cause plus noble
est-ce la vie qu'on veut un jour tous
terminera nous serons à court de soldats
l'objectif est de vivre de vivre en paix
y arriverons-nous
recrutés comme premier astronaute
israélien il s'investit pleinement dans
la mission STS 107 et les nombreuses
expériences scientifiques qu'il va
devoir accomplir dans son journal il
écrit qui aurait cru que je serai le
premier israélien à survoler la terre et
mon pays
[Musique]
le research de Born major ou RDM va
faire son vol inaugural sur sts107 conçu
par les Américains de la firme space hab
il est assez similaire au Space Lab
conçu par les Européens et sert les
mêmes objectifs offrir un lieu dédié aux
expériences en orbite transformant la
navette en un véritable laboratoire
spatial space hub avait déjà fourni à la
NASA le single modo un concept similaire
mais très limité en taille le RDM promet
comme son nom l'indique de doubler cet
espace pour maximiser les expériences
scientifiques lors de STS 107 les
astronautes vont se relayer 24 heures
sur 24 pour les réaliser à la manière
des missions spatiales scientifiques
précédentes
comme d'habitude pour ce genre de
mission on divise l'équipage en deux
équipes la rouge et la bleue dans la
rouge
osband Shola Clark et Ramon et dans la
bleue MacCool Brown et Anderson parmi
les 59 expériences à l'intérieur du
spaceb 21 sont commandités par des
firmes privées 14 par l'Agence spatiale
européenne une au profit de la Station
spatiale internationale et 23 pour
l'obpr le bureau de recherche en
médecine et biologie de la NASA
l'utilité de certaines d'entre elles est
capitale on peut citer l'expérience MGM
qui va compresser des matériaux
granuleux en apesanteur dans l'espoir
d'améliorer les techniques de
construction en particulier pour les
fondations de bâtiments en zone sensible
au tremblement de terre inondations et
glissement de terrain
une autre vise à étudier des cristaux de
protéines dans le but de mettre au point
d'éventuelles thérapies pour prévenir de
la formation de certains cancers et de
calmer leurs symptômes en dehors du
module pressurisé des expériences sont
également stockées dans la soute et
exposer à l'espace et ne requièront pas
d'intervention de l'équipage elles sont
placées sur le toit du Spacehab mais
aussi sur les palettes externes hitch
aiker et Edo au total ce ne sont pas
moins de 80 expériences qui vont se
dérouler à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur de la navette pendant deux
semaines en orbite dont certaines
initiées par des écoles d'Australie de
Chine d'Israël du Japon des États-Unis
et du Liechtenstein
même si l'entraînement au système de la
navette et aux expériences scientifiques
et primordiales la façon même dont la
mission est conçue impose à l'équipage
d'être soudés malgré les problèmes qui
pourraient survenir en orbite en 1985
Taylor when s'envole pour sa première
mission spatiale STS 51b l'objectif
principal est de réaliser des
expériences sur le Space Lab un module
laboratoire placé dans la soute après le
lancement tout semble aller excepté pour
l'expérience que doit faire Taylor Wang
qui refuse de fonctionner la pression
sur lui est énorme puisque bien
qu'américain il est le premier
astronaute d'origine chinoise dans
l'espace
avec ce stress ajoutez au mal de
l'espace et l'impossibilité de réaliser
son expérience
Wayne développe une grave dépression
selon Mike Mulan astronaute de la NASA
les toilettes de la navette sont ensuite
tombées en panne ce qui a forcé
l'équipage à revenir à la bonne vieille
technique d'Apollo faire ses besoins
dans des sacs en s'aidant de leur main
gantées
Taylor Wang a trouvé sa propre solution
il refuse de faire ses besoins pendant
plusieurs jours il se retient et refuse
de manger quoi que ce soit de solide ce
qui aggrave évidemment son état
psychique inquiet ses collègues
n'arriveront pas à le rassurer et même
si son expérience finira par fonctionner
il ne retournera plus jamais dans
l'espace
c'est justement suite à ce précédent et
d'autres que la NASA insiste sur la
cohésion des équipages et pour sts107
organise une sortie en nature de 10
jours dans la National outdoor
leadership school un camp dans les
montagnes Rocheuses au programme détente
partagées de la nourriture rationnée pas
de téléphone et de l'eau purifiée en
réalité ce stage a de nombreuses
similarités avec le vol spatial comme
durant le vol ils doivent résoudre des
problèmes avec seulement le contenu de
leur sac à dos se laver d'une façon plus
que spartiate et bien prendre soin de
leurs affaires ce séjour en forêt leur
permet également de découvrir les forces
et faiblesses de chacun de mieux se
connaître et bien sûr d'éviter les
conflits qui pourraient poser des
problèmes durant la mission
des guides locaux assiste l'équipage sur
les premiers jours de randonnée mais se
retirent ensuite et les laisse se guider
par eux-mêmes chaque jour un membre
d'équipage différent prend la direction
des opérations et ce chef du jour est
évalué par les autres en fin de journée
[Musique]
le lancement est initialement prévu pour
août 2001 mais à l'instar de la majorité
des lancements de navette STS 107 va
subir d'importants retard retour de STS
93 Columbia est envoyé en Californie
pour subir des travaux de maintenance et
d'amélioration important estimée à plus
de 160 millions de dollars la navette
revient en Floride comme neuve mais en
retard sur le programme initial plus
vieil orbiteur de la flotte elle est
également la plus lourde ce qui l’exclut
des missions d'assemblage de la Station
spatiale internationale seul deux
missions lui sont donc assignés avant sa
retraite définitive sts107 mission
scientifique et STS 109 pour réparer le
bal
le télescope qui subit une série de mal
fonctions au début des années 2000 va
devenir la priorité de la NASA STS 109
va donc partir avant sts107 ce qui
retarde encore cette dernière
Columbia revient de sa maintenance
debbel en mars 2002 et retourne au
hangar pour être préparé à sa toute
dernière mission on lui retire son bras
robotique la plateforme d'amarrage du
télescope et on installe le laboratoire
Spacehab l'opération est assez rapide et
on estime alors que le lancement de STS
107 pourrait avoir lieu en juillet 2002
mais en juin c'est un problème
potentiellement grave qui va de nouveau
entraîner un report
des fissures sont repérées au niveau des
moteurs principaux d'autres navettes de
la flotte ce qui implique un démontage
complet de tous les moteurs pour
inspection d'autres missions volent
tandis que Columbia est au sol et une
fois les moteurs inspectés et les
fissures comblés ce sont d'autres
fissures sur d'autres composants qui
imposent d'autres inspections et
réparations les mois passent au plus
grand bonheur de l'équipage qui en
profite pour passer du temps avec les
familles et par faire l'entraînement à
la mission les autorités américaines
sont particulièrement soucieuses de la
sécurité entourant ce lancement en
raison de la présence d'un Israélien à
bord et l'atmosphère menaçante qui suit
les attentats du 11 septembre en plus de
la date de lancement qui sera annoncée
au dernier moment les astronautes et
leurs familles sont sous-escorte
constante et en Floride les véhicules
sont soumis à des fouilles et contrôles
réguliers par les militaires américains
[Musique]
la soute de Columbia est définitivement
fermée le 31 octobre 2002 et la navette
est ensuite rattachée au réservoir
externe et au booster avant d’être amené
sur le pas de tir 39A en décembre le 16
janvier 2003 Columbia est prête et ses
astronautes s'installent à bord asband
McCall Brown et Shola se place dans le
cockpit tandis kanderson Clark et Ramon
sont dans le pont inférieur ces trois
derniers n'auront donc pas le luxe de
voir le lancement les hublots étant
absents à leur niveau à 10h39 heure
locale Columbia s'élance à destination
de l'orbite pour la dernière fois de sa
longue carrière
[Musique]
le décollage en apparence c'est passé à
merveille cependant des ingénieurs
tirent la sonnette d'alarme sur un
impact de débris sûrement de mousse qui
a frappé l'aile gauche de Columbia ils
espèrent qu'une inspection visuelle
pourra être réalisée par les astronautes
en attendant l'équipage ouvre la soute
rapidement et active les systèmes du
laboratoire orbital le travail commence
vite et bien un seul petit problème
survient un des deux déshumidificateurs
permettant de récupérer et rediriger de
l'eau dans le Space AB produit des
étincelles une situation qui les
préférable d'éviter dans l'espace
le problème est vite résolu et
l'équipage désormais divisée en deux
équipes suivent le lourd programme
d'expérience scientifiques qui les
occuperont 24 heures sur 24 pendant les
16 prochains jours en parallèle sur
terre des ingénieurs de la NASA se
réunissent et échangent des emails au
sujet de l'impact de mousse sur l'aile
gauche certains d'entre eux font des
demandes auprès du Département de la
Défense américain pour que des
satellites spion photographie la navette
ce qui avait déjà eu lieu lors de
mission précédente mais les hauts
responsables de la NASA estiment que ce
serait superflu l'agence n'a visiblement
pas non plus envie de connaître
l'étendue des dégâts vu qu'il est de
toute façon impossible de faire quoi que
ce soit que ce soit des réparations ou
une récupération par une autre navette
le 23 janvier le directeur de vol Steve
Stitch informe l'équipage de l'impact
il n'y a aucune inquiétude à avoir en ce
qui concerne le RCC ou des dommages sur
les tuiles nous avons vu ça sur d'autres
vols et ça ne posera pas de problème
pour la rentrée le RCC c'est le bord
d'attaque de l'aile en carbone renforcé
il est notamment utilisé pour les
disques de frein des formulants et même
du Concorde cette partie est considérée
par les astronautes comme un vulnérables
tant elle est résistante à ce moment
précis la NASA a peu d'informations sur
la zone d'impact et pense que les débris
de mousse pourraient avoir frappé les
tuiles placées sous l'aile et au vu de
l'angle pourraient n'avoir fait que des
dégâts mineurs quant au RCC bien que
mentionné lors des réunions il est selon
les ingénieurs sûrement intact
[Applaudissements]
le 29 janvier 2003 l'équipage est
réveillé par la chanson Imagine de John
Lennon William McCall après avoir écouté
sa chanson préférée dira de notre unique
point de vue en orbite nous observons la
terre sans frontières paisible et
magnifique et nous prions pour que
l'humanité imagine un monde comme nous
le voyons actuellement sans frontières
et ayant le désir de vivre unie et en
paix les expériences sont un vrai succès
mais au sol des ingénieurs continuent à
débattre des potentiels dommages de
l'aile gauche et des procédures
possibles dans le cas où la chaleur
endommage le système de déploiement du
train principal gauche
pour autant la NASA ne prend aucune
décision ferme
le 30 janvier les préparations du retour
sur Terre commencent progressivement les
expériences sont éteintes et les
résultats stockés ou transmis sur terre
David Brown écrit un dernier email à ses
parents le moment le plus émouvant pour
moi c'est quand j'ai lu une lettre
qu'Ilan Ramon a amené à bord écrite par
un survivant de l'Holocauste dont la
fille de 7 ans avait perdu la vie
j'étais choqué du fait que des choses si
horribles pouvaient arriver sur une si
belle planète
le 1er février 2003 la navette effectue
sa rentrée dans l'atmosphère
Evelyne hausband attend son mari sur la
piste du Kennedy Space Center ce
matin-là une minute avant l'heure prévue
d'atterrissage j'ai demandé à Steve
Lindsay astronaute escorte des familles
Steve dans quelle direction ils vont
arriver
Steve avait un regard vraiment étrange
Clermont pas le genre que je voulais
voir à ce moment-là il a pointé une
direction dans le ciel puis a décroché
son téléphone
ensuite le compte à rebours de retour a
indiqué 0 et je savais que j'aurai déjà
dû entendre les banques supersoniques à
témoin une minute mais c'était le
silence total sur la piste
j'ai commencé à avoir peur
j'ai regardé Steve et je lui ai demandé
quand vont-ils se poser pourquoi il n'y
a pas eu de Bang mais il était toujours
au téléphone tous les responsables
étaient au téléphone à se lever et
courir de partout
mes enfants Laura et Mathieu me tiennent
la main et me demande si leur père va
bien je me rappelle maître retourné vers
Kiss le frère de Rick pour lui demander
pourquoi on n'avait pas entendu les
bangs
il m'a répondu qu'il n'y en aurait pas
il savait déjà et la mère de Rick
s'était fondée et moi aussi
après son discours d'annonce de
l'accident à la nation le président Bush
place le Texas en zone sinistrée afin de
faciliter les recherches de débris une
commission d'enquête est créée le CIB
pour Columbia accidents investigation
board en 2003 le contexte international
est particulier cela fait un an et demi
que le pays a été frappé à New York et
au Pentagone la guerre en Afghanistan
fait rage et l'Irak et sur le point
d'être envahi avec un astronaute
israélien à bord de cette mission la
piste terroriste est évoquée mais vite
écarté au vu de l'altitude et la vitesse
de la navette aucun missile n'aurait pu
l'intercepter
l'impact de la mousse isolante sur
l'aile gauche est très vite pointée du
doigt comme la possible cause de
l'accident mais pour faire la lumière
sur le déroulé précis des événements il
est primordial de continuer à collecter
les débris des bénévoles se joignent aux
recherches tandis que d'autres
retrouvent et tentent de vendre des
débris sur ebay un élément en
particulier de Columbia pourrait aider à
résoudre le mystère de l'accident
l'enregistreur au ex
cet instrument qui enregistre les
données de plus de 570 capteurs de la
navette peut être considéré comme la
boîte noire de Columbia présent sur
aucune autre navette il a été installé à
l'époque des tous premiers vols de
l'orbiteur en 1981 pour évaluer les
performances de vol d'autres restes vont
se révéler déterminants durant les
premiers jours de recherche Carl Vita et
Marty pontet Corvo vont retrouver une
cassette vidéo près de Palestine au
Texas a Houston sa lecture va émouvoir
l'ensemble de la communauté spatiale on
y voit l'équipage durant la rentrée
atmosphérique filmée par l'astronaute
Laurel Clark
c'est 13 minutes montrent les
astronautes qui rient et changent des
commentaires sur le spectacle de la
rentrée atmosphérique tout en déroulant
leur check-list la vidéo s'arrête une
quinzaine de minutes avant l'accident
cette vidéo même si elle ne montre pas
ce qui s'est passé durant la
désintégration de la navette permet aux
enquêteurs de voir l'état émotionnel des
astronautes un facteur important
rendu public ce document montre encore
aujourd'hui les dernières images de
l'équipage avant leur décès
[Musique]
le 18 mars 2003 art Baker explore un
terrain vallonné près de empire au Texas
quand il trouve le fameux enregistreur
au ex dans un état remarquable il est
emballé avec précaution et envoyé au
Minnesota pour être nettoyé puis
transférer au Kennedy Space Center avec
tout autant de soins pour faire une
copie il termine son voyage à Houston où
son contenu va être décodé et analysé en
détail
l'enregistreur a pu recueillir des
informations précises sur tous les
systèmes jusqu'à 9 heures zéro minute et
18 secondes ce qui correspond au moment
exact où les témoins au sol ont constaté
les premiers signes de désintégration de
la navette
il est désormais clair que les données
de l'oex seront déterminantes pour clore
l'enquête
durant les recherches de débris qui
prennent plusieurs mois les hélicoptères
quadrillent la zone dont celui de Jules
Mayer et Charles Trenet employé du
service forestier national américain le
27 mars 2003 alors qu'il survole la zone
de recherche à basse altitude leur
moteur se coupe à moins de 40 mètres du
sol au ras des arbres les deux pilotes
ne peuvent rien faire
l'hélicoptère s'écrase dans une forêt de
Brodus les deux pilotes sont tués sur le
coup et leur 3 passagers employés
respectivement de United space aliens le
service forestier et la NASA sont
blessés crennac et mayor seront les 8e
et 9e victime de Columbia
[Musique]
pendant ce temps en Floride le hangar
RLV bâti pour préparer les navettes X33
à leur mission et réaffecté par la NASA
pour l'enquête de sts17 on trace au sol
des carrés et on dispose les débris de
façon à reconstituer Columbia au total
ce sont plus de 83 000 morceaux de
différentes tailles qui vont arriver
dans le hangar récupérer aux quatre
coins du Texas et de ses états voisins
de février à mai 2003 cela équivaut à
38% seulement de la navette mais
certains de ces débris s'avèrent
important pour l'enquête comme les RCC
les tuiles ou encore les panneaux et
interrupteurs du cockpit
dans le RLV une ingénieur de la NASA
prend le travail de reconstruction tout
particulièrement à coeur son nom Anne
miclos elle a entretenu une relation
amoureuse avec l'astronaute David Brown
pendant 3 ans dans le hangar elle est
responsable de l'équipe de
reconstruction les tuiles de Columbia
c'était à la fois personnel et
professionnel pour moi et je voulais
comprendre ce qui s'était passé
comme moi les gens dans leur hangar
étaient détachés émotionnellement mais
c'était difficile de voir ça les
premiers morceaux reçus étaient les plus
humanisants comme les cadres de hublot
jamais on aurait imaginé que c'est de
cette façon que la navette ne
reviendrait c'était dur mais c'était
nécessaire afin de traverser ces
émotions et tourner la page
on retrouve également des restes des
astronautes et de leur combinaison ce
qui permet de mener des autopsies et
mieux comprendre les derniers instants
de l'équipage au fil des semaines la
commission d'enquête se concentre de
plus en plus sur la problématique des
débris frappant la navette au décollage
et fragilisant le bouclier thermique ils
vont alors reprendre tout l'historique
des vols de navettes à la recherche de
précédents et étudier le bord d'attaque
de l'aile les panneaux RCC
après l'accident de challenger qui a
coûté la vie à cet astronaute en 1986
l'émission navette reprenne STS 26 ouvre
le bal en 1988 puis STS 27 durant la
phase d'ascension de cette dernière
l'équipage voit des morceaux blancs
frapper les vitres du cockpit une
inspection est réalisée par des caméras
sur le bras robotique mais vu que cette
mission est pour le compte de la Défense
américaine les images reçues par les
ingénieurs de la NASA sont en partie
brouillés et il considère que ce ne sont
pas des dégâts sévères pourtant une
partie de l'isolation des SRB a frappé
la navette au décollage et le commandant
de la mission inquiet informe les
contrôleurs au sol qu'il ne manquera pas
de dire ce qu'il pense de leur
conclusion optimiste s'il constate que
la navette est sur le point de brûler
lors de la rentrée le 6 décembre 1988
Atlantis revient en un seul morceau au
sol mais les dégâts sont considé
700 tuiles sont gravement endommagées et
une tuile manque à l'appel heureusement
sous la protection thermique manquante
une plaque d'aluminium presque
totalement fondue à empêcher la navette
de se vaporiser un incident a été évité
et de peut la Commission se penche
ensuite sur les RCC on reconstruit dans
un hangar le bord d'attaque de Columbia
sur lequel on projette de la mousse
isolante à grande vitesse le résultat
surprend tout le monde
Charles Bolden ancien pilote de navette
et ancienne administrateur de la NASA
parlera des RCC jamais dans ma mémoire
et même en fouillant dans mes notes
jamais nous parler des RCC le bord
d'attaque de l'aile celui de la dérive
ou même le bout de nez personne n'a
jamais réfléchi à la possibilité d'avoir
des dégâts sur ces parties parce que
nous pensions tous qu'elles étaient en
pénétrables en réalité ce n'est que
quand on a perdu Columbia que j'ai
appris à quel point c'était fort j'ai
grandi dans le programme spatial j'ai
passé 14 ans à voler dans ce programme
tout en pensant que le bord d'attaque
était une masse épaisse de 10 ou 15 cm
quand j'ai appris après l'accident de
columbiax n'était que des fractions à
peine de centimètres d'épaisseur et
qu'elle n'était pas plus résistante que
la fibre de verre d'une carrosserie de
voiture
ça m'a ouvert les yeux
la lumière est alors faite sur le
déroulé précis de l'accident
le premier février 2003 la navette fait
une poussée de désorbitation et commence
sa descente à travers l'atmosphère vu
que Columbia fait sa rentrée de l'Ouest
jusqu'à l'est des États-Unis des
passionnés ont leur caméra braqués dans
le ciel dans tous les États du Sud 4
minutes après le début de la rentrée
atmosphérique alors que l'équipage filme
les flammes tout à fait normal à travers
les vitres du cockpit des débris sont
éjectés de l'aile gauche et sont vus par
des témoins au sol observant la rentrée
depuis la côte ouest une minute après
les contrôleurs à Houston perdent le
contact avec quatre capteurs de
température sur l'aile gauche
sans que personne ne le sache l'aile
gauche est en train de lentement se
désintégrer
[Musique]
la navette survole le Nevada l'Utah
l'Arizona puis commence une série de
manœuvres prévues qui se déroule
parfaitement elle entre au
Nouveau-Mexique et au sol le télescope
Starfire de l'USR force enregistre cette
photo infrarouge révélant une nette
anomalie sur l'aile gauche l'ordinateur
engage le compensateur de l'aileron pour
tenter de corriger la symétrie du flux
aérodynamique au bout de 4 minutes une
faible compensation ne suffit plus et
l'aileron est déployée au maximum
au même moment la chaleur est-elle à
l'intérieur de l'aile gauche que les
capteurs de température n'affichent plus
aucune information les astronautes
reçoivent une alerte indiquant la perte
des capteurs de pression du train
principal gauche les compensateurs de
l'aileron n'arrivant pas à compenser la
symétrie les RCS de l'arrière droit
s'activent pour aider à corriger la
trajectoire leur poussée devient
continue mais ne suffit toujours pas a
Houston on informe l'équipage des
problèmes de capteurs sur l'aile gauche
ce moment coïncide avec la perte de
contact attendu lors de la rentrée
la vitesse du son des tuiles commencent
à se détacher un troisième propulseur
RCS s'active pour compenser la symétrie
puis un quatrième
Houston ne peut pas communiquer avec
l'équipage et ne reçoit aucune donnée de
la navette
le système hydraulique touché par la
chaleur dans l'aile seront totalement le
nez de la navette se lève et le contrôle
n'est plus possible
Columbia entre dans une vrille à plat à
ce moment là un des astronautes sur le
pont inférieur termine les préparations
d'atterrissage et tentent de s'attacher
à son siège les astronautes ont leur
visière de casque relevée comme la
procédure le vœu et certains n'ont pas
encore mis leurs gants le pilote et le
commandant incapable de corriger la
trajectoire passe la navette en mode
pilotage automatique ce qui n'a aucun
effet l'équipage n'aura pas le temps
d'enfiler leur gants et de baisser leur
visière peu de temps après l'aile gauche
puis les portes de la soute s'arrachent
augmentant la fragilité générale du
corps central de Columbia avec la
chaleur s'engourant dans la soute et les
contraintes aérodynamiques l'avant du
fuselage se sépare du reste de la
navette au niveau de la soute les deux
ponts du cockpit sont dépressurisés
instantanément les lumières s'éteignent
et les astronautes non protégés père de
connaissances presque immédiatement plus
aucun membre d'équipage ne respire
désormais et plus rien n'est possible
pour les réanimer à ce stade
l'avant de la navette tourne lentement
sur lui-même et les attaches des sièges
ne fonctionnent pas suffisamment bien
pour les maintenir fermement les
secousses infligent aux astronautes des
blessures létales la chaleur s'engouffre
désormais dans tous les interstices de
la partie avant de la navette
l'enregistreur de données cesse de
fonctionner et la partie avant finie de
totalement se désintégrer
[Musique]
après l'accident la flotte de navette
est clouée au sol ce passage à vide
impactera particulièrement la
construction de la station spatiale
internationale qui dépend principalement
des orbiteurs américains pour
transporter et installer les nouveaux
modules et structures cette pose se
terminera en juillet 2005 avec une
condition cependant les vols se
concentreront uniquement sur les
livraisons de modules pour la Station
spatiale internationale et la
maintenance du télescope spatial Hubble
sts107 sera donc la toute dernière
mission scientifique orbitale de
l'histoire des navettes spatiales
trois nouvelles procédures naissent
également suite à l'accident de Columbia
d'abord les navettes reçoivent un nouvel
outil l'Obs une extension du bras
robotique lui permettant une fois en
orbite de scruter le bouclier thermique
et le fuselage dans le moindre détail à
la recherche d'éventuelles dommages
ensuite chaque navette se rendant sur
l'ISS doit effectuer une sorte de salto
appelée rendez-vous pitch manover de
façon à ce que les astronautes de la
Station filment et photographie la
navette sous tous les angles les images
sont transmises au sol et s'il y a des
tuiles manquantes ou d'autres dommages
Houston peut diriger une sortie extra
véhiculaire pour réparer tout dommage
enfin on met en place l’émission 3x6 et
400 pour la plupart des lancements de
navette qui ont lieu après l'accident de
Columbia une autre est présente sur le
pas de tir voisin avec un équipage prêt
à décoller
cela permet si la navette n'est pas
réparable de partir récupérer l'équipage
et de le ramener sur Terre à bord de la
navette de secours
ces missions ne seront jamais
nécessaires mais l'une d'elles STS 400
restera comme la plus connue lors de la
dernière visite auprès du télescope
Hubble Atlantis se trouve sur une orbite
bien différente de celle de l'ISS ce qui
rend un éventuel sauvetage impossible si
des dégâts sont repérés sur le bouclier
la mission sts400 est donc mise sur pied
la navette ndvor sur le pas de tir 39B
se tient prête à aller secourir les
astronautes de STS 125 en cas de
problème
heureusement Atlantis n'aura aucun dégât
au décollage et sera en mesure de
terminer sa mission sur rebelle
toutes ces nouvelles précautions vont
tout de même montrer leur utilité dès le
retour en vol des navettes en 2005 lors
du vol STS 114 premier vol d'une navette
après l'accident de Columbia d'autres
morceaux de mousse se détachent du
réservoir externe et l'un de frappe
l'aile droite de Discovery avec cette
fois une puissance trop faible pour
l'endommager le problème est tout de
même pris très au sérieux l'inspection
par l'Obs révèle tout de même un défaut
sur les tuiles à l'avant de la navette
une fois amarrée à la Station spatiale
internationale Stephen Robinson
réalisera des réparations lors d'une
sortie spatiale ce qui donnera lieu à
ses photos extrêmement détaillées du
dessous de la navette
[Musique]
suite à l'accident la société Spacehab
concepteur du module d'expérience
demandera un dédommagement à la NASA
pour la perte de son module à hauteur de
87,7 millions de dollars l'agence ne
versera que 8,2 millions comme prévu
dans le contrat initial et ce même si la
firme annoncera poursuivre la NASA avant
de finalement renoncer avec l'amandon
des missions de navettes en dehors de la
construction de l'ISS et de la
maintenance de balle Spacehab nous
fournira plus de modules de recherche à
la NASA et les Space Lab européens
seront également cloués au sol
définitivement
sur un plan plus décent les astronautes
de STS 107 rejoindront les grands noms
de l'exploration spatiale américaine
dont Neil Armstrong jeune young ou John
Glen en recevant la médaille d'honneur
spatiale du Congrès
parmi les 28 astronautes l'ayant reçu 17
le rond obtenu de manière posthume les
équipages d'Apollo 1 STS 51l et
sts107
Ilan Ramon israélien et de fait le seul
non américain à recevoir cette
décoration une partie de son journal de
bord sera retrouvée et restaurée aux
côtés d'un disque de yeruda policare
nommé dust and HS comme un signe seul 4
mots sont lisibles dust and ashes Ilan
Ramon
son journal intime est aujourd'hui en
partie exposée en Israël et des extraits
sont disponibles dans certains livres
son fils Asaf s'engagera dans l'armée de
l'air israélienne et comme son père
tiendra lui aussi un journal il trouvera
la mort dans un accident aérien lors
d'un exercice
doté d'esprit penseur et rêveur père et
fils l'agron des récits émouvants sur la
poursuite de leurs rêves de voler
en 2004 le rover martien Spirit se pose
dans le cratère goucef sur l'horizon 7
collines se dessine nommée Columbia
Hills chacune d'entre elles portent le
nom d'un astronaute de sts107 leur nom
est le patch de la mission apparaissent
également sur l'antenne à hogain du
rover
[Musique]
en 2011 Atlantis est la dernière navette
à se poser en Floride et met fin à l'air
des orbiteurs aujourd'hui la flotte est
exposée un peu partout aux États-Unis et
en Floride Atlantis et la portant encore
les stigmates de sa dernière rentrée
atmosphérique sous ses ailes un mémorial
a été créé pour les équipages de
challenger et Columbia et deux débris
sont exposés l'un de challenger à gauche
et la structure du pare-brise de
Columbia à droite le reste des débris
est entreposé dans le véhicule assemblée
building du Kennedy Space Center quant
au bras robotique de Columbia retiré
avant sts107 il est aujourd'hui exposé
au Musée de l'aviation et de l'espace du
Canada
chaque début d'année est organisé le
NASA day of remembrant un jour où l'on
commémore la mémoire des astronautes
d'Apollo 1 de challenger et de Columbia
à travers les États-Unis
attitusville en Floride nous avons pu
assister au remèdes day de 2018 qui
s'est déroulée quelques jours après la
cérémonie principale au Kennedy Space
Center en présence d'astronautes
attitudes ville il y avait moins de
monde mais était notamment présent
Winston Scott astronaute et Lowell
Grisom frère de Ghost RESAM qui a péri
lors de l'incendie d'Apollo 1
un mémorial se tenait là avec une plaque
pour chaque astronaute tuer lors de
mission spatiale une cérémonie émouvante
qui fait prendre conscience de l'esprit
de conservation de la mémoire de
l'histoire spatiale américaine comme on
peut le constater avec le nombre de
musées spatiaux en Floride centrale ce
qui nous a le plus marqué là bas c'est
leur volonté de conserver tout ce qui
touche à l'histoire spatiale de leur
pays et la dignité avec laquelle ils le
font c'est un bel hommage à ceux qui ont
perdu la vie dans cette grande aventure
qui est l'exploration spatiale
[Musique]
même si Columbia fut détruite lors de la
rentrée atmosphérique la majorité des
expériences ont survécu à la mission
l'une d'elles CVX 2 avait été embarqué
sur la mission pour étudier la manière
dont le xénon se déplace en apesanteur
le disque dur contenant les données a
été retrouvé endommagé mais lisible
parmi les débris en avril 2008 ces
résultats ont permis la publication
d'une étude scientifique donnant de
nouvelles réponses à un problème de
physique sur les fluides non newtoniens
la raie au fluidification
l'expérience d'études des matériaux
granuleux a été transmises avant la
rentrée atmosphérique et a été considéré
comme réussi à 60%
le petit bidon de métal contenant des
vers de terre a été retrouvé au Texas et
à la grande surprise des scientifiques
ces petits êtres ont survécu à la
destruction de la navette la chaleur de
la rentrée et la Chute Libre leur
descendants partiront eux aussi dans
l'espace cette fois à bord de l'ISS avec
la mission STS 134 la même expérience de
biologie de sts107 a été réalisé sur les
vers de terre de l'ISS montrant qu'il
ressentent les effets de la pesanteur de
la même façon que les humains avec des
conséquences sur leurs muscles et les
symptômes diabétiques enfin on citera
laisser du système de recyclage d'eau
lors de STS 107 qui aujourd'hui permet
de recycler la majeure partie de l'eau à
bord de la Station spatiale
internationale et permet sur terre
d'économiser cette précieuse ressource
dans les zones les plus arides
le travail de l'équipage de STS 107 n'a
donc pas été 20 et a permis de faire
avancer plusieurs champs d'études
scientifiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
yeux
[Musique]